the first 11 years of the MCU are done
the nfinity saga was great but the
future of the MCU has never been more
exciting how's it going everybody it's
Warren and the future of the MCU is just
right around the corner and although we
are going to miss many things about the
first 11 years Iron Man and Captain
America of course fans have never been
more excited about the MCU especially
with all of these new characters coming
and Kevin Feige the president of Marvel
Studios himself mentioning mutants and
the Fantastic Four at San Diego Comic
Con and I know with all the rumors and
the leaks that are going on right now it
could be hard to keep track of what
movies are expected to be coming in the
future so today we're going to talk
about every one that has been reported
to be coming in phase four phase five
and future phases as well
quick reminder I'm giving away an Xbox
one or a ps4 winners choice so be sure
to subscribe to my channel like this
video and leave a comment below with
your favorite superhero or villain so
you can enter my giveaway for a chance
to win so credit to Reddit user pomo
gemma underscore SW in and for putting
this list together and with this list
will also be the sources of where the
reports have come from all of which on
this list have come from sources that
have been right about things in the past
so all pretty reliable sources but let's
start off with the ones that are for
sure the ones that are confirmed and
have been mentioned by Marvel themselves
and the ones we have on those lists
right now are black panther 2 guardians
of the galaxy vol 3
Captain Marvel 2 blade Fantastic Four
and x-men now of course Kevin Feige has
already announced Black Panther 2 and
given the massive success that Black
Panther number one had we knew it was
coming of course guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 has been confirmed as well and we
know James Gunn is returning to direct
the movie and reports say that he even
has his script finalized but
unfortunately he has to finish Suicide
Squad first for DC and that comes out in
2021 so guardians of the galaxy vol 3 is
expected no earlier than 2022 and then
of course we know that Captain Marvel 2
is coming we are just unsure when then
of course we have blade which was
announced at San Diego comic-con
followed by the Fantastic Four and the
x-men blade was announced with the logo
and before San Diego comic-con ended
Kevin Feige said we didn't even have a
chance to talk about the mutants and the
fantastic for confirming that they are
in fact in development even if it is in
very early development and since then
Kevin Feige has stated a few times that
they are indeed working on these films
so these are the movies coming in Phase
five that have been confirmed by Marvel
themself now let's talk about movies
coming in Phase five or beyond that have
been confirmed by other sources this
list includes Ant Man three Deadpool
homewrecker spider-man 4 Nova Silver
Surfer and the New Avengers Ant Man 3
was recently confirmed by Charles Murphy
who has a very good track record with
leaks many people have been worried
about Ant Man 3 many fans love these
films but we're unsure whether or not
they were going to continue with the Ant
Man franchise or if they were going to
put ant-man in a Disney Plus series
instead of doing movies and as far as
Deadpool goes many people have reported
that Deadpool 3 is soon to be on its way
to the MCU Ryan Reynolds himself has
teased this and has even posted a photo
to Instagram with him inside of Marvel
Studios and not to mention the writers
for Deadpool 3 have mentioned that it is
in fact going to take place inside of
the MCU so we knew this one was coming
but spider-man 4 has been reported by
deadline.com now deadline is a very
reliable source and they say that a
fourth spider-man film is going to be
coming to the MCU which makes a ton of
sense because recently as we all know
Disney and Sony made a deal for
spider-man to stay in the MCU and
considering how big of a deal it was it
probably wasn't a deal for only one
movie so a spider-man for coming to the
MCU makes perfect sense then we have
Nova who has been reported to be coming
by Daniel RPK and Mikey Sutton also not
to mention Nova has been talked about by
Kevin Feige before and said that he is a
priority character to introduce into the
MCU which makes sense because we know
that he was supposed to be introduced in
the first guardians movie and we know
that he was supposed to make an
appearance in Avengers infinity war but
never did then we have a Silver Surfer
movie and this has been reported by
geeks worldwide now of course this is
something that everybody would
absolutely love to happen and of course
Kevin Feige has stated that the
Fantastic Four are coming so of course
that means the Silver Surfer can't be
too far behind and geeks worldwide is a
pretty reliable source and if you also
take into consideration the fact that
Galactus is probably coming and is going
to be
next big bad of the future of the MCU it
makes sense that the Silver Surfer would
come Galactus has been reported to be
one of the next big bad villains of the
MCU by many different sources at this
point in time it's been reported that
there's going to be two villains of the
MCU a ground villain which will be the
main villain on earth and a cosmic
villain which will take place in the
cosmos of course and of course that big
bad cosmic villain is going to be the
one and only Galactus the Devourer of
worlds and again this has been reported
by multiple sources including Mikey
Sutton and MCU cosmic but going back we
know that if Galactus is coming Silver
Surfer is not going to be far behind
and it's a great opportunity for Marvel
to get the Fantastic Four the Silver
Surfer and Galactus right many fans were
very disappointed with the Fantastic
Four the rise of the Silver Surfer that
Fox put out and not to mention many fans
were really disappointed in the very
last Fantastic Four movie that came out
as well so this is a great opportunity
to redeem the Fantastic Four inside of
the MCU and then we have the new
Avengers which of course we knew was
going to be coming at one point in time
Marvel is not going to stop doing
Avengers films now will they be the same
no of course not we're not going to have
Iron Man and we're not going to have
Captain America it will never be the
same as the original lineup however that
does not mean that it's not going to be
fantastic especially with the Fantastic
Four coming to the MCU the x-men coming
into the MCU and not to mention all of
the other new characters that we're
getting plus some of the old characters
that have been building up for a while
now so the New Avengers although is not
going to be the same and we're not going
to have the same nostalgic feeling that
we've had for the original Avengers is
still going to be awesome nonetheless
and the New Avengers are supposedly
going to be led by spider-man Captain
Marvel and Black Panther and this is
widely believed to be the big movie of
2024 so although it's going to be some
time until we get a new Avengers movie
it is going to happen and then we have
the Disney Plus shows that are said to
be in development right now for Phase
five and beyond as well and these shows
include Doctor Doom reported by MCU
cosmic Miss America reported by geeks
worldwide Valkyries by Mikey Sutton
Weapon X by doll turd double-oh-seven
war machine that was reported on 4chan
not too long ago and Lady SIF which was
reported on 4chan as well now the cool
thing with Disney Plus is that Kevin
Feige has already stated that it's
to directly connect to the MCU
everything that happens in the Disney
Plus shows will take place in the MCU
so now Marvel has a new precedence with
the MCU they don't have to announce and
reveal and introduce characters directly
into movies anymore instead they can
take their time and build them up and
give you their backstory through Disney
Plus this is something that Marvel loves
to do and they do it better than anybody
else they slowly introduce characters
and they slowly build them up over time
and Disney Plus is a new great way to do
this and Disney Plus can be used for new
characters and old characters for
example it has been reported by MCU
cosmic that we could get a Doctor Doom
Disney Plus show Doctor Doom is a huge
villain one of the greatest Marvel
villains of all time and if you think
about how fan OHS was built up he was
built up over years and in years but
when it came down to learning about his
backstory we only learned a little bit
about it in Avengers infinity war and
Avengers in game and if you're planning
on introducing an insanely big villain
like Doctor Doom it would make sense for
you to build him up as well but with
Disney Plus we now have the opportunity
to give him his own story before he
becomes this insanely large villain we
can learn all about his backstory and
what led him to becoming the villain
Doctor Doom while at the same time we
have characters like war machine that
have been around before but are loved
enough to get their own stories for
Disney Plus and of course remember these
Disney Plus series tied directly to the
MCU Kevin Feige has stated that the
events that happened will influence the
movies that happen in the MCU as well so
really what's happening with Disney Plus
is that the Marvel Universe is vastly
expanding and then we have three more
possible movies or Disney Plus shows
that have been reported as well we have
Power Pack reported by Charles Murphy
and MCU cosmic Young Avengers by various
different sources and the Dark Avengers
by Charles Murphy now the power pack and
the Young Avengers are certainly going
to be great additions to the MCU
especially for the younger viewers and
the MCU has definitely been setting up
the Young Avengers especially in
Avengers in game but Avengers endgame
did also lay the groundwork for the Dark
Avengers to come especially if Sony and
Disney during the spider-man deal worked
out a deal for Norman Osborn to come
into the MCU which according to reports
was actually supposed to come in
spider-man far from home now obviously
we never saw him
but the old Avengers tower is in fact
being turned into something new
and it has been reported that that is in
fact Oscorp tower now if this was in
fact supposed to be in spider-man far
from home we do not know the reason that
it was taken out it could have been
taken out because Disney did not know
which way the Sony Disney deal was going
to go with the future of spider-man and
if you can't introduce Norman Osborn due
to a deal falling through with
spider-man why introduce him at all but
of course this is just speculation for
right now but if Norman Osborn enters
the MCU there is a really good chance
that we could see at the Dark Avengers
so these are all the movies and Disney
Plus shows that are reported to be in
development for phase 5 and beyond be
sure to let me know what you think about
these and be sure to let me know which
one you're looking forward to seeing the
most out of all of these there really is
a lot to look forward to with this list
there's the x-men the Fantastic Four
Doctor Doom The Young Avengers and the
New Avengers so we have a really
exciting feature to look forward to in
the MCU so leave your thoughts in the
comments down below also don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you can
stay up to date on everything relating
to the MCU and so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 I'll also be starting giveaways
on Twitter and Instagram soon so you can
follow me on there as well and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof